Do you have any additional information about calcium supplementation?
I don't know about additional information you're talking about because I'm not a super
big fan of calcium supplementation unless the person has diagnosed with metastasis to
the bone and or diagnosed with a decreased calcium bone formation and then even with that
you still want to use MK4, MK7 with the calcium. We have a product at our store
it's a call, look at that. It's the only one that I recommend, osteo K, that's the
name of it. It's got vitamin D, it's got calcium only 200 milligrams and two
calcins. You think, wow, that's not very high, that's right. You don't want to
ever take high-dose calcium. So if you take high-dose calcium it's going to be
deposited in your arteries and that's going to cause atherosclerosis. You do not
want to ever take high-dose calcium and it's really the the vitamin K2 as the
MK4 form that is going to be the most important to help give calcium into the
bones. Otherwise it's just going to be deposited in the arteries and you're
going to end up with hard issues. So don't ever let any practitioner convince you
that you need to take high-dose calcium. That is just not the right thing to do
taking. So I should do it, I don't think I have blog posts about this, I don't
have to make one.